today's classic interview is really
straightforward in terms of what I
discussed with Jonathan metzel about
three years ago three and a half years
ago mental health gun databases obvious
right you create a database it helps
people uh not get guns it helps to
prevent people who shouldn't have guns
from getting them however one
lesser-known aspect of those mental
health databases uh are that they are
incredibly racially tinged and Jonathan
metzel join me in February of 2013 to
talk about that let's go back to that
important topic joining me is Johnathan
metzel he's the director of Vanderbilt
center for medicine health and society
his last book the protest psychosis
deals with how schizophrenia has become
a disease associated with an over
diagnosed with black men I want to talk
about this Jonathan first kind of
specifically uh your findings and then
later talk a little bit about the gun
debate that's going on and how this may
tie into the so-called mental health
databases so first let's talk about the
overdiagnosis part tell us about your
research there absolutely so I it's
interesting for me that actually the two
topics that you just mentioned overlap a
great deal that the kind of central
narrative of the book and of the
research that I've been doing since the
book looks at interesting and troubling
cultural phenomenon which is the over
diagnosis of schizophrenia and
african-american men which really
started according to data in about the
1960s it was interesting for me to find
in my research that prior to the 1960s
we thought of schizophrenia as an
illness that was most often associated
with really docile white women so in the
30s 40s and 50s in the United States he
would see movies and films and even
hospital Asylum wards where
schizophrenia was a notice that was
applied to white house wives or women
who were kind of troubled or in need of
psychoanalysis or psychotherapy is this
what attention is this an extension of
those ads that sometimes float around
about how to deal with nervous women and
hysteria and that type of thing that was
totally part of that story so at the
time people thought that schizophrenia
was almost a neurotic or personality
condition there was a famous movie
1948 called the snake pit with Olivia de
Havilland and it told a story of a kind
of erotic white woman who went crazy
when she got married and so there was
this whole kind of cultural or around
the culture of psychoanalysis at the top
they kind of sent the message not only
that schizophrenia was an illness of
white women but also that schizophrenia
was an illness of docility so a lot of
times you would see these women as being
kind of troubled or as you mentioned
neurotic but nobody was really afraid of
them there was no cultural discussion
that Oh people with mental illness might
be violent or hostile or dangerous and
what I found was that all of a sudden in
the 1960s quite literally in a five or
ten year period you see that all of a
sudden kind of out of nowhere this this
real fear of mental illness and part of
what's happening is that there's a
different association with schizophrenia
in which all of a sudden people started
associating schizophrenia not only with
angry black men but also with violence
at that time and so all of a sudden in
the 1960's and 1970's you see a host of
cultural representations that basically
talk about angry black killers that are
on the loose or schizophrenic black men
that want guns they're FBI most wanted
lists that all of a sudden start showing
angry black men with schizophrenia and
so really what you see it in this very
reason it is this all of a sudden this
association I kind of changing the
assumptions about the race and the
gender of schizophrenia they're really
extend into the present day and one
thing that I make up I've been doing a
fair amount of kind of relations about
that about the gun violence issue and
one thing I point out is that we didn't
always think about people with months in
general and people with schizophrenia in
particular as being violent in a way all
these transformations have in the 1970s
and they were linked to two
transformations race as well so this is
interesting when we talk more
specifically about the gun debate that's
going on now because i had a
conservative on the show a couple of
weeks ago and we were trying to kind of
have some kind of consensus about what
are effective ways of reducing gun
violence and then he was talking about
well we need to really keep guns out of
the hands of people who are most likely
to commit violence with them and he used
a lot of what i considered to be kind of
racially coded terms including uh the
children of single parents
urban areas and uh you know drug-related
gun homicides and all these things which
speak very clearly to me with with
racial connections and it's interesting
that even the idea of a mental health
database could be racially coded if you
think that it's going to be overly it
it's gonna over represent misdiagnosed
schizophrenia in african-americans am i
off on that absolutely yeah you're
absolutely right about that i would i
would make to two separate points about
that and one let me just say that uh but
before i even make any points about it
let me say that I don't think I can't be
entirely critical of this association
between mental illness and and violence
because when we see these horrific
crimes like what happened in Newtown or
in Colorado or you know the string of
horrific crimes that we've seen it in
Arizona um there is I think a
justifiable human impulse just say that
what's happening now is not saying that
in a way a normal person will be doing
us and we struggle for words to
understand what had happened and
certainly also in the incidence of a lot
of these mass shooters there are
different kinds of illness histories and
so in that sense I don't think that the
the rush to assume that there's a mental
illness connection is entirely something
that's entirely problematic because it
helps us make sense of what's happening
here at the same time it's troubling for
a couple of reasons and one is that as
an aggregate group I think that the data
on gun violence is really a pretty
unconvincing in terms of who's
committing who's committing the crimes
and so even leaving the race issue aside
people with mental illness are far more
likely to be the victims of violence
rather than the perpetrators of this
association that we need to fear the
mentally ill is really kind of an
inversion of what's happening in the
real world in which people with mental
illness in violence in general and also
gun violence are far more likely to be
attacked because of you know a variety
of reasons and so one is that we're kind
of promoting the stereotype of the
violent mentally ill person when really
reality does not does not bear that out
at all and the second point is you
mentioned is that there is a racial
component to this and I say that because
in the research I've done I've looked at
the
60s and 70s and there was a different
debate about guns at that time there all
of a sudden in the 60s and 70s people
like Huey Newton and people in the Black
Panthers and Malcolm X and other people
robert williams a double a CP leader in
the south we're arguing that
african-americans needed to arm
themselves in order to protect
themselves against racist aggression and
so there were movements of you know this
you know violence is as natural as
cherry pie and movements to arm black
people and all of a sudden white society
started saying no that's mental illness
that we don't want black people to get
arms and what they did was they passed
the voting right act of nineteen sixty i
mean i'm excuse me the gun control act
of 1968 and so in a way at that moment
there was this kind of fear this
racialized fear that that that tied into
the gun debate at the time and it led to
kind of association between guns and
really black protests well the double
rendered in the hypocrisy is also
fascinating because back then it was
mental illness to think that you needed
guns to protect yourself from racism at
the same time now we have this entire
group of individuals saying they need
guns to protect themselves in many cases
from the possibility of a tyrannical
government or of any other number of
things but nobody's bringing up that
that idea is is mental illness that's
never suggested now no and you're made
my point exactly i mean i think that's
exactly the point that what we see in
the 60s and 70s is that when people like
huey newton were saying we need guns
society was very comfortable at
pathologizing what it called black
culture in the present day when we have
shooters who were very often white
troubled white males it's never all we
need to blame white culture for that
crime it's always you know this is a
lone troubled individual and the mental
illness part plays right into it we say
oh it's it's just this one person it's
not a cultural debate and so really just
the fact that these shooters are white
and we have a very different cultural
response i think is part of the kind of
as you say very strong double standard
that we have here a second point that i
would make is that if you look at the
you know recent Pew Research
african-americans are far more likely to
support gun control it's upwards of
seventy percent far more likely than
white Americans just for gun control and
so in a way a lot of this NRA kind of
talk is really being driven
I mean it's very hypocritical to say
that it's coming from you know inner
cities and stuff like that when people
Lea inner cities what gun control more
than anybody i think we've been speaking
with jonathan metzel director vanderbilt
center for medicine health and society
the book is the protest psychosis
Jonathan great to have you on I want to
have you back to talk about the next
question which is what will be actually
the effect on gun purchases of these
proposed mental health databases but
we'll leave that for next time terrific
thank you so much i would love that